do you worry about
cyber war in the 21st century absolutely
yeah if there is a global war it'll
start with cyber you know if it's not
already started
do you feel like there's a
like a boiling like the the drums of War
are beating what's happening in Ukraine
with Russia it feels like the United
States becoming more and more involved
in the conflict in that part of the
world and China is watching very closely
is starting to get involved
geopolitically and probably in terms of
cyber
um do you worry about this kind of thing
happening in the next decade or two like
where it really escalates you know
people in the in the 1920s
were completely terrible at predicting
the World War II
do you think we're at the precipice of
War potentially I think we could be I I
mean I I would hate to just be
you know just fear-mongering out there
um you know and covet's over so the next
big thing in the media is war and all
that but I mean there's some some Flags
going up that are very strange to me is
there a ways to avoid this I hope so I
hope some Barner people and I are
figuring it out I hope people are
playing their parts and and talking to
the right people
um because that's the war is the last
thing I want well there's two things to
be concerned about on the Cyber side one
is the actual defense
on the technical side of cyber and the
other one is the Panic that might happen
when something like some dramatic event
happened because of cyber some major
hack that becomes public
I'm honestly more concerned about the
panic because
I feel like if people don't think about
the stuff the Panic can hit harder
like if they if they're not conscious
about the fact that we're constantly
under attack I feel like it'll come like
a much harder surprise
yeah I think people will be really
shocked on things I mean so we talked
about low SEC today and Lil sick was
2011. they had access into a water the
water supply system of a major U.S city
they didn't do anything with it they
were sitting on it in case someone got
arrested and they were gonna maybe just
expose that it's there's insecure maybe
they were going to do something to [ __ ]
with it I don't know but you know that
that's that's 2011. you know I don't
think it's gotten a lot better since
then
and there's probably nation states or
major organizations that are sitting
secretly on Hacks like 100 a hundred
percent they're sitting secretly waiting
to expose things
I mean I again I don't want to scare
this [ __ ] out of people but people have
to understand the Cyber threat I mean
there are you know they are there are
thousands of nation-state hackers in
some countries I mean we have them too
we have offensive hackers you know the
the terrorist attacks of 9 11.
there's planes that actually hit actual
buildings and it was visibly clear and
you can trace the information with cyber
attacks say something that would result
in the ex in a major explosion in New
York City
how the hell do you trace that
like if it's well done it's going to be
extremely difficult the problem is
it there's so many problems one of which
the US government in that case has
complete freedom to blame anybody they
want true and then to to go start war
with anybody
anybody that actually see uh all right
that's sorry that's one cynical take on
it of course no but you're going down
the right path I mean the guys are the
food planes in the buildings wanted
attribution they took credit for it when
we see the Cyber attack I doubt we're
gonna see attribution maybe the victim
side the US government on this side
might come out and try to blame somebody
but you know like you've brought up like
they could blame anybody they want
there's no really a good way of
verifying that